meine These war dass er dann keine
sonderkriegsziele erreicht und wir sind
ja ich glaube schon wenn ich nur noch
Freunde habe in Nordkorea viel mehr ist
da nicht mehr übrig ist man schon
ziemlich isoliert er kriegt keine
westliche Technologie also ich würde das
nicht schön reden es gibt ja eigentlich
in Deutschland nur die AFD und die
Wagenknecht Leute die bestreiten dass
der was ansonsten gibt es den Streit
über die Frage Militär Logik Ja oder
Nein ist die Toleranz für die andere
Position nicht besonders ausgeprägt ist
sondern man wird immer der Putin
narrative verdächtig wenn man nicht
glaubt das kann
militärisches Problem ist der deutschen
Debatte ja ich habe ihn das schon
mehrfach gesagt dass sie ihre Haltung
sehr respektiere man kann die auch haben
nur die Frage nach der Lösung ist die
große Frage ich bin nicht ganz mit ihnen
der Meinung dass Russland seine Ziele
nicht erreicht Russland brüstet sich
740.000 Kinder entführt zu haben das
Rote Kreuz spricht von etwa 200.000 und
die Ukraine sagt sie können nachweisen
das ist über 20.000 oder um die 20.000
Kinder waren erst 378 zurück
[Musik]